i don't like i have never liked i've
been very vociferous about the sports
field being utilized
to advance messages because it's a
pandora's box
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is the
businessman and the former owner and
chairman of crystal palace football club
simon jordan welcome to trigonometry
nice to be here boys
it's great to have you on the show
thanks for coming on my pleasure uh
we've got a big international audience
so some of them might not be familiar
with you and your background and your
story
tell everybody a little bit about who
are you how are you where you are what
is the journey that brings you here
sydney talking to us
um public domain staff i mean i was born
born and brought up in south london
my father started as a footballer moved
into being a printer
and i was born in south london 100 yards
away from a football club that i ended
up buying
i started working in a city when i was
19 years of age in computing
felt i was the best thing since sliced
bread found out that i wasn't morphed
into doing something in the sales
industry
had a couple of businesses didn't go the
way i wanted to went to america got some
experience over there for two or three
years
trying to start businesses over there
came back when i was 24
started to work for charles dunstan at
the carphone warehouse because the
mobile phone industry was something i'd
known from a previous incarnation
had a couple of years 18 months with him
built him one of the most successful
parts of his business looked at him
thought
there's nothing particularly special
about you guys that i can't do
so i went out and started the business
became the second largest mobile phone
retailer
in the uk after five years 257 shops
2 000 staff and huge ambition
i decided there's two ways for me to go
i can float this business and i'm not
sure that telcos at that particular time
were the right propositions to float 20
years ago or
given the expansion program given the
fact that i'd started with 15 grand and
built it into the
the empire that was there with 257 shops
i just described
we were under capitalized what do i want
to do do i raise some capital do i want
to float or do i
want to sell so i took an opportunity to
do at the time and i still think remains
now the biggest private industry sell
and sold it took it 78 million plus some
stock
and walked away with an ambition to do a
variety of other things
one of the things that came onto my
horizon was the football club that my
father played for that i'd been bought
i've been born 100 yards away from
supported all my life and had to sign
school boy forms for when i was a kid
it was industry you were quite a
promising player yourself yeah i was
yeah i'd signed
for chelsea and moved on from chelsea to
palace when terry venables was quite a
well-known sports figure at the time
um was in his pump at crystal palace it
hadn't worked out for me
football is not just about talent it's
about mental application and
and a pure unadulterated desire to be
successful
that doesn't mean it doesn't translate
an adulterated desire to be successful
doesn't translate into other fields but
football playing wasn't my calling in
the end so i morphed into the other
things i've just described
but come back 14 years and the
opportunity if you want to describe
owning a football club as an opportunity
came my way and i figured hmm this is
the next frontier
sports not so much franchises but sports
opportunities
were becoming more exciting the
broadcasters were becoming more invested
the opportunity was beginning to become
what i felt more grown up and mature and
i thought what's the worst thing can
happen
it's a bit like the dr pepper moment be
careful what you wish for you know
what's the worst thing that can possibly
happen so i bought
crystal palace 10 years i've owned it on
my own was arduous and financially
challenging 2009-2010 with a variety of
businesses i was invested in which
wasn't just football clubs it was film
production companies it was restaurant
groups
it was car magazines it was spanish
properties american properties
and a variety of non-risky things
brought me to an economic challenge
which involved me
ultimately losing the football club
handing it on to others
and then moving on with a different
phase in my life which brings me to
writing books and having intellectual
capital to invest in businesses
and now having some fun with
broadcasting so there you are there's
the guided tour
because i can get to it and i used to do
talk sport i used to do overnights at
talks yeah i did indeed so
but um i've been watching you talk about
sport and that's the reason we wanted to
get you on because we thought you were
absolutely brilliant thank you it's a
very very interesting moment for sport
at the moment because we see more and
more politics and sports start to merge
unfortunately that's true yeah and i
would just we'd just like to get your
take on it what do you think about it
and do you think it's a step in the
right direction
when you say politics i think sport is
being leveraged by politicians at times
you know when you look at the current
climate in england
with the landscape of professional
football and the government trading off
opportunities because there's
political capital to be made whether
it's using sport to
to rail against the uh the online
operators and with the online harms bill
being brought in by the governments
and sport being very vociferous about
abuse
whether it be racial or whether it be or
any kind of abuse
so the government have been vociferous
in that respect it's also been over the
years
a stocking filler if you look at the
labour party 10 15 years ago suggesting
that part of their manifesto was the the
idea that they were going to enforce
football clubs to have
an opportunity to for fans to have 10
every time ownership changed
not practical and of course we've got
the societal issues more than the
political ones where sports really
being i don't know if you want to say
leveraged but certainly harnessed
by good and bad causes i think and of
course we've seen a very challenging
year
in the last 12 months for a variety of
reasons you know for the bleeding
obvious of covert 19
but we've seen some of the aberrations
in society we saw the dreadful events
in america with george floyd which have
then been you know
afforded opportunities for people to
bring certain initiatives forward
right and wrong ones superimposing some
of the things that happening in america
into our country i'm uncomfortable with
but not we're standing at
equal opportunity and discrimination
are two things that need to be looked at
very carefully equal opportunity of
course
doesn't mean equal outcome but equal
opportunity is a fundamental right that
everybody has
and sports can play a part in that i
don't like i have never liked and i've
been very versatile about the sports
field being utilized
to advance messages because it's a
pandora's box you open that box for one
cause you've got to open it for all
and i understand that there's some
causes that are more worthy than others
you know and there are some animals that
are more equal than others according to
george orwell but we are
in a world where sport entertainment the
purpose of sports
in my view is to take people out of gray
lives give them 90 minutes of
entertainment in the world of football
terms
and then put them back with something
that's altered their afternoon good and
bad
not to be leveraged for agendas
so my trouble with the the idea that
it's been politicized i think it's been
a genderized more than politicized
but there is an element of politics
being played into place when you've got
movements like black lives matters and
other
uh scenarios where sport will try to be
like you know legend you know leveraged
for various advances and i'm very
comfortable
for high profile sports stars to use
their platforms
but i'm not comfortable for the pitch to
be used i'm uncomfortable with that
i'm uncomfortable with the methods that
are being deployed at times
and i'm uncomfortable with the manner in
which the method messages are being
imparted by some of the mainstream media
that leverage sport and also have their
own bias
it's a it's a really really good answer
what you've just said about the agenda
ising of sport and it's happened
particularly
very very quickly over the past season
yeah what is your opinion of
you know taking the knee do you think
players should be
should be allowed to do it or do you
take the olympic approach which is
there should be no politics over
politics in sport
at all well my view is that there
shouldn't be any politics in sports
i think that stars of sport now have
such a platform in a variety of
other environments that they can utilize
the image they want
and i'm not comfortable with the pitch
being utilized or the stadium or
whatever you want
now i know there will be arguments that
suggest that there are other causes that
are advanced whether you put a poppy on
someone's shirt you're doing the same
thing and i hear that argument
i think they come from a different point
of view but i understand it
i'm also uncomfortable with the
not so much a tokenism of taking the
knee
the genesis of that has been hijacked
it's been hijacked from what colin
kaepernick did
which started with the fact that he was
wasn't in
wasn't in the camera line so he was
sitting on the bench sitting down when
the national flag
was being celebrated before every single
game and then because
because he wasn't getting the attention
he took a knee to demonstrate against
the oppression and the racial inequality
and the abuse of black men and the
police brutality
now i'm troubled by that because
bringing that into an environment in
this country
where i do not believe i'm not black
obviously and i and i cannot look at the
world through the eyes of a black person
i have a i have mixed race in my family
i've been brought up in south london
and i understand some of the dynamics of
it but i can never actually
walk through someone's shoes or have
someone's lived experience is the is the
expression
and you know and if i don't agree with
things of course unconscious bias will
come to play in the minds of those that
whose opinions i don't agree with but i
was always troubled with the taking of
the knee
and the reasons why i was troubled with
the taking of the knee is not because it
came from game of thrones that one of
our [ __ ] politicians said
or because it symbolized subservience
it's because it represented something
that a political politically motivated
organization
had attached themselves to and whether
people like it or they don't like it
black lives matter as a statement is
something i'm very comfortable with
black lives matters as a movement
is something i'm very uncomfortable with
because i think their agendas and their
outlook
and their their destruction or their
ideals behind the destruction of society
whether you've got antifa in the mix
or whether you've got a whole range of
ideas that
that disrupt capitalism destruct society
defund police and god knows whatever
else they want
to have that agenda dropped into a sport
by association was a trouble for me
and the reasons why i i made certain
observations which people
were uncomfortable with they were
uncomfortable within the framework of
the broadcasting platform that i use at
times
and there was misrepresentation because
it was an example in england
with a particular football club that has
a notorious background or a little bit
of infamy
um that where an issue had arisen that
players were taking the knee and the
fans were booing
it and i raised the question because i'm
very very focused on mainstream media
activity
and the agenda rising and the
misrepresentation and the
lack of nuance that they want to put on
when they want to sensationalize things
and i
questioned the idea that this booing was
simply because the fans were racist
rather than after a stable diet had been
force fed into our minds
about blm we had seen people running
around
in london defacing statues
you know running around spray painting
winston churchill's
statue with the blm moniker and we had
also been
indoctrinated by mainstream media about
the existence
of black lives matters as a movement in
america and its origins and its thinking
and it was to me unfathomable that
people there wasn't a possibility
that people were rebelling against the
concept of
black lives matter's the political
motivation rather than the statement
that of course
black lives matters so i was
uncomfortable
with that and subsequently the
association with the taking of the knee
the players themselves find it ambiguous
they had to make statements before games
even though people said this is very
clear people like you
simon are choosing not to understand
what this means
you're choosing to select the messages
you want to hear well i'm not
because if it was so clear then the
people that were taking the knee
themselves wouldn't need to put out
statements
to reinforce that they were kneeling for
anti-discrimination
and then we move into the territory of
having been a football club owner
been inside this industry and i'm very
troubled
with the fact that the allegation is
that the football industry is racist
and there's racism within the confines
of it or our society is racist
systemically is the allegation and
i was troubled by these things because i
concur and accept and abhor racism
in every form and i see it on the
terraces
but i didn't see it in the industry and
just because statistics
are the beginning of a conversation they
don't mean they're the end of it and
statistics were being brought up
about the football industry being racist
because there wasn't enough
representation
and i wanted to question the reasons why
i don't want someone to give me
a fact without support i don't need
someone to tell me
to educate myself and then if i cut if i
don't come around to their way of
thinking
go away and educate myself some more
right i have my own views and
often they're based upon experience and
having been an owner in a football club
having been an owner of a football club
in a multi-ethnic environment
driven by multi-ethnicity and never
having an application
from the black community i'm struggling
with the idea
that the game is racist at its core so
the issue for me was what are you
actually kneeling for you're kneeling
for societal issues
and i'm not sure that sport should be
held up as the poster boy or leveraged
to be such it shouldn't be held to a
higher standard
because i don't think that's fair on
sport i think that's wrong and those
that want to do it
are people that are trying to genderize
it for their own end game and not
necessarily for the benefit of those
they purport
to represent and see that that
misrepresentation that you talk about
where you say i don't support blm the
organization
but i support blm black lives matter the
slogan
is actually what people call the modern
bailey tactic where you present
something
which is defund the police abolish
capitalism etc
and the moment anyone criticizes it you
retreat
to the position well you're you're
saying black lives don't matter which of
course is
it's a payload switch yeah exactly
exactly but you know i think one of the
just to step back a little bit more one
of the reasons people love sports so
much is at least they perceive it as a
meritocracy
right indeed uh people think and i don't
know you tell us whether this is true or
false
that you know the whole point about
sport is if you're good you're going to
succeed if you're not you're not going
to succeed that's the ideal that's the
ideal
is that accurate in terms of the premier
league and football in general
or do you think there is discrimination
and people from certain backgrounds
are kept out even though they're more
talented enough no i don't i don't i
don't think
i think football is a landscape where
and i don't mean to be flippant
knowing most of the 92 football club
owners they would have employed osama
bin laden
if they thought they thought we could
win games for them so it doesn't they
don't prejudice against color or creed
that you know
the only thing that's prejudiced in
football is integrity because there's
not a lot of it going on from the pitch
upwards
you know from players cheating through
to the current climate of football club
owners wanting to do precisely what they
want with
zero concern about the rest of the
ecosystem albeit
that ecosystem was already destroyed by
20 clubs in the premier league that
couldn't give a monkeys about the other
72 clubs in english football so there's
a lot of hypocrisy
in the world of sport but meritocracy
yes of course
meritocracy whether it's whether it's
economic meritocracy
or it's sporting prowess within the
confines of football the economic power
and might
of the big clubs in english football
and the talent that they are able to
attract is part and parcel of two things
economic meritocracy and sporting
merchandising
the challenge i have is that sports need
governance it needs to mature
in these proper governance and the
landscape of sports
those that can affect those that can't
unfortunately in football because of the
collective relationships of how football
is
held together how sports like football
are held together
so those that can the argument that
football should
oh football's going bankrupt or clubs
are getting themselves into trouble they
should have the nancy reagan mentality
of just say no
to the next player transfer it's for the
birds
because football is a public domain
business that's driven by sentiment
driven by momentum driven by demands and
having been an owner
that didn't lose his head but still
wanted to try and
satisfy my own ambitions of the fans
ambitions there are different
forces that come to pass and if you
haven't got governance in sports
specifically financial governance
and then you've got nation states that
buy football clubs that are worth 320
billion quid and they can buy who they
want when they want
and they drive the price up for
everybody else and then the fall back
fall down effect is everybody else gets
affected by it then it becomes a very
challenging
landscape and those are the things that
i would have i rail against
in the incarnation i have now which is
broadcasting alongside other things that
i do
at the same time as remembering how i
railed against it whilst i was in it
so sporting meritocracy of course it
exists
because the best are clearly the best
the opportunities based
upon color and creed and ethnicity are
not denied in sports
because the four corners of the world
fling forward the talents
and the opportunity exists ever more in
sport because the
channels are far wider open because
people are looking for talent
across the four you know the four
corners of the world so
no i don't believe emphatically do not
believe
some of the nonsense has trotted out
that certain communities are
precluded and excluded from
opportunities and that's not because i
sit here as a middle-aged white man with
the luxury of having white privilege is
because i sit here
not sitting in the world of theory and
live in a world of experience
and those are some of the things i find
very difficult with the mainstream media
if you listen
some of the broadcasting which i know
you have done i spend a lot of my time
really teeing off on the mainstream
media because i
object to the manner in which things are
represented i object
to some of the ideas that were advanced
when we had these dreadful situations on
clapham common
with that vigil for that poor girl that
was murdered
and then we see the police being
brutalized and people piling in
and politicians suggesting that we've
got to have apologies left right and
center because nothing now
that you do in life doesn't come with an
apology and even if you apologize for it
it's still not good enough
yet when we find out the real truth
behind these sort of events
we never see the people that made the
accusations of politicians like kia
stammer
or other people that came out davey that
came out and
vilified police never come back up again
and say well actually we were wrong we
should be apologizing now so i'm
i am very across these things and have
very strong views about it and i just
want authenticity i want honesty
you know we can all cope with honesty we
can all cope with the truth being told
to us
because it's far more compelling than
some of the misrepresentations and the
danger that we live in
in this society is so often you know
we're through the looking glass
what's up is down you know what people
want to show you
they don't show you nuance they show you
a binary and we're living in a binary
world and it's not right
to live in a binary world because
everything has nuance there is a
qualification behind most things
and people have the right to see a
little bit more than they do see and
deserve better i think at times
it's a big part of the success of our
show because we offer that alternative
people we said well
it's good to have you on but listen the
question i was gonna please don't take
this as an insult but
you were a very wealthy man when you
purchased crystal palace you're
still a very wealthy man now but you are
a pauper
by comparison by comparison to the
people who own football clubs now
absolutely the scale of opportunity and
the scale of individual that have come
in for a variety of reasons
you know some would say remember a brand
which bought chelsea is a very expensive
life insurance policy
and the motivations behind the middle
eastern consortiums may well be sports
washing if you want to make those
allegations
people buy football clubs for a variety
of reasons some for credibility some
recognizability
some for sure adoration you know and
you're absolutely right
that the association of wealth now is
far greater
to you know to be an owner of a football
club when i made a hundred million quib
when i was 31 years of
age whoa i was something special by
comparison i'm a waiter now in economic
terms and why do you think there's
anything wrong with the game
do what do you think the impact of that
is on the game do you think that's been
for the benefit we see the best players
in the world playing in the premier
league or or do you think it's been
you know our arsene wenger famously
described it as as financial doping
whilst drawing 10 million year salary
i um i think with all money um
comes an element of corruption and
pollution and the changing of agendas
and the changing of motivations
and i don't just mean when it will cost
mentality i mean that you know money
does take away the age it does take away
the desire it does take away
the the fight within you because it
softens you and it you know and it takes
away
some of the the integrity of the sport
because we are seeing a sport now driven
by money
we're seeing the ugly side of sport
specifically and explicitly in the last
two weeks with the
premier league and the so-called super
clubs trying to
find a mechanism to generate more
revenue
which by the way i don't disagree with
because we've got a situation where
the player salaries are so far out of
control there's no reset even despite
the worst economic landscape that we've
seen for the sport
probably since the second world war has
not done anything to reset the financial
opportunities for players so these six
clubs in england and the six clubs and
the rest of the europe and whether
the biomedics of the world and whoever
else we're going to come in at later
stage will never know
or never know in this incarnation um the
the issue was
about the loss of sporting meritocracy
but to go to your theme
of the financial side of it it is just
that it's just the reality of the world
that we now live in
and when i had a vision 20 years ago
looking at sports thinking bloody
difficult business far easier ways to
keep my money let them make some more
um but i do believe there's a landscape
here i've been
railing for some time about sports
not needing broadcasters like sky
anymore and having the ability
to be able to deliver their own content
the netflix a football idea that i've
been mooting around
which i believe was part of the esl's
thinking we'll do our own tournament
then we'll build our own platform they
will monetize ourselves and we'll
dwarf whatever revenues but finance
the world turns on finances everything
whether we like it or we don't like it
the economics of life from the lowest
common denominator the highest
totem poll is about money it turns the
world whether countries invade other
countries to preserve
oil reservoirs or whether football clubs
are spending
ridiculous amounts of money at the
center of most of it is money
so do i like it well i'm a grown-up
i accept it's a reality i'd like
governance i'd like control over our
support so that
because there's nothing wrong with
football clubs making money
um and there's nothing wrong with owners
making money except according to fans
because any people are allowed to make
money are players agents and
managers which is just for the birds for
me
but i'm i'm not troubled by it i'm just
troubled by the lack of governance
and the lack of control because sport is
unique
we can't forget i'm of course i say it's
business
because when you're playing football as
two hundred thousand pound a week
as almost disgusting as that is for what
they're actually doing in comparison
what some people are doing in society
that are far more valuable as we have
seen
over the last 12 months you know it's
it's difficult
to justify it but we are where we are
we are where we are and you know i don't
see that landscape
changing anytime soon we've just got to
mature try and make sure that the
industry and protect these football
clubs at the same time because there's a
part of me that thinks they should have
a blue plaque over the door you know a
bit like
a listed building and have a certain set
of
protections because they are part of the
community they are part of the unique
values of this country
and any country that's got football
clubs that and and sports
environments that are very important to
them but we are now moving into the
territory in this country where we sell
everything don't
we you know we're quite prepared to
learn the stock exchange not so long ago
so why wouldn't our community products
like football clubs be sold
i just and and again not to be too
uh waxing lyrical about the value of
football clubs
i love football fans i grew up being a
football fan i value the football fans
but they're part of the problem because
they're the ones that scream for the
next billionaire to come in
and the challenge for me is is how do
you
deliver back on their expectations when
their expectations are unrealistic
football started as a working person
sports when you start flying players
around the world in private jets
it's a business and when you start
attracting billionaires in there
you have to grow up and realize why
these people are there they're not there
because they like moss side
and they're not there because they like
the king's road they're there because
there's an opportunity and a reason for
them to be there and it isn't because of
the love of the football club they may
develop
an affinity an association with it but
it'll always be a conduit and vehicle
for whatever other ambitions aspirations
and ideals people of that ilk may have
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course
incredible interviews hilarious live
streams
hard hitting satire plus my handsome
jawline
whatever takes away from your hairline
but if you do love trigonometry and you
want to support us
there's only one place to do that and
that's on locals
yes locals is a brilliant platform that
has been incredibly supportive to our
show
and other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community
for people who love trigonometry that's
right it's a place for you to hang out
with like-minded people
share thoughts memes and discuss the
show you can enjoy it for free
but it also gives you the option of
supporting us for
as little as seven dollars a month and
if you want to give more
you can we have incredible rewards for
our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group course and one on two chats with
me and kcat get
in join our community by hitting the
link in the description
and the pin comment below see you there
guys
and simon we were talking about just
jumping back a little bit
to the earlier part of the interview
where you were talking about the sport
not being racist
i suppose the one consistent argument
against that is the issue of black
managers
yeah why are there so few black managers
when i think is it
something like 40 perhaps more of
footballers a black or mixed race
128 black footballers in the premier
league
out of something like six 700 of which
64
are english 64 uh 65
are from overseas clubs or overseas
parts of the world which means they tend
to go back there you've had
25 of the clubs in this country employ
black managers
the problem is they're the same black
managers they're chris shuten they're
jimmy floyd hasselbank they're pauline's
is football responsible for a certain
community stepping up is there a
blockage
i've asked the question on a number of
occasions and i never get an answer
because i question it not because i want
to question it not because i'm
uncomfortable with it not because i'm a
white man that wants to protect his
position because i want to know what the
problem is
once you know what the problem is you
can fix it i don't want hyperbole
i don't want the the the the theory i
want the fact
why have we got a blockage i know the
football club owners i know who they
wouldn't
wouldn't wouldn't employ and why they
wouldn't wouldn't employ them i i see
them
applying germans i see them employing
portuguese i see them employing italians
so the notion that they wouldn't employ
people from the black community i
struggle with then i try to get answers
say right okay we got if we are if this
game is
wrecked with institutional racism
because you often hear institutional
racism as a thing as
as a scenario it's brought out and
people make these sweeping statements
and then they don't justify them i heard
uh institutional racism is that more
black women die in childbirth
boom that's an example of institutional
racism my first question after that is
why and then i get greeted with silence
is it because
uh more black women have more children
is it because there's a congenital
defect is there a linguistic challenge
is there reasons behind this so-called
institutional racism because i thought
27 percent
of the national health service were from
the black community
i thought there was a leaning towards
making sure that there's a correct
balance within the framework of
of uh i've just had a baby boy so i'm
looking for experience
and institutional racism being trotted
out without an understanding of it is
something that i find
challenging so when i get into the
football world and say well okay you're
telling me
that there's a systemic racist problem
in football i can't see
why i never and i fired managers for fun
i never had an application from a black
manager
for a job at a football club which was
multi-ethnic
which had black players black supporters
and i had black coaches and i employed
people
from all communities when people
approached me oh well simon
you're the exception no i'm really not
the exception right
so what is the issue i try to get the
statistics through
okay tell me the the channels are open
for black managers to
to to to be successful in how many black
coaches have we got that being qualified
and getting their badges because part of
the ability to be a manager english
football is you have to have coaching
qualifications
what are the statistics are we producing
thirty percent of the coaches
that are coming through from the black
community and only six percent of the
jobs
or is it ten percent of the coaches that
are coming through
are black and and six percent of them
are getting and the statistic the six
percent so
there's not this big disparity but i
never get an answer
i get a central theme i ask people i ask
questions
about what does institutional racism
look like in a country
that it has 25 percent of the cabinet
from
black and minority ethnic groups that
has the chairman of the conservative
party
james cleverley being a man from the
black and the black community
i look at the mayor of london and see
that opportunity from that community and
i say to myself
if we are an institutional society sorry
an institutionally racist society
how are these situations manifesting
themselves and i read up on critical
race theory to understand the mechanisms
behind it and i speak to educated people
for more science
and the answer i get back is these
people are uncle toms
these people are gateways from morphing
into one community to another i said
well i can't win
then because there isn't a critical
thinking behind your thinking there is
a motivation to suggest that unless i
see your point of view i have
unconscious bias
i have white privilege and i struggle
with these things
because i really do believe as a man and
as a human being
that everyone has the right for equal
opportunity
but not equal outcome jordan peterson
trope i know but notwithstanding it
still relevant
and i look at that and say we are moving
into a world
of quotas and representation
of every single group so we'll now have
a country and a business environment
that's made up of so if you're going to
put people on boards because of their
color you've got to put them on there
because of their age because of their
sexuality
because of their you've got to put you
know people that are disabled to
represent that quota so all of a sudden
you'll have a country made up of quotas
and we will go to the dogs
because talent will be moved to one side
and quotas will be there and if we want
that kind of world
then be careful what we wish for so i
have these views whether they're right
or wrong i don't sit there with a
blinkered point of view saying
my way's the right way i have a binary
outlook i want to know
why you're saying these things to go to
your point do i believe it's a close
shop do i believe it's racist do i
believe there's a problem
i think the problem exists much amongst
the community that are complaining about
it
not wanting to advance their own
opportunity because they're i know the i
know the argument it's well rehearsed
we're good enough to be in the theater
as the actors but we're not good enough
to be the impresarios
i i hear that nobody is stopping people
from any community from buying a
football club
you know anyone's money is the same
color
and i speak to you know people within
the game and i ask the question about
racism in football
trevor sinclair is a very good friend of
mine trevor tell me what racism have you
experienced in football
well i've been called rude names by the
fans i'm sorry the fans are societal
issues
and football clubs have a zero tolerance
policy but what racial
issues have you had that have stopped
you from advancing and being able to be
successful in your field and there the
conversation stops
because i i don't want to discredit the
arguments i don't want to not
not to sit there and say that if you
believe it to be true then i have to
accept your views
but i want to be told how it can be
fixed because if
you if you live in a world of hypothesis
and you don't get to the real issue then
you'll never fix anything because what
you're being told isn't the real issue
of course there's a representation issue
but why
is that not just a statistic statistic
it's the beginning of a conversation
now we've got to get to the root cause
of the reason for the lack of
representation
in sports the least you know the reason
for lack of representation from the
asian community once upon a time michael
chopra
was an asian footballer that played for
newcastle that was owned by a friend of
mine said john hall
douglas hall was was a very close friend
of mine because we lived together next
to one another in spain
and they felt that michael chopra was
the beginning of the asian
opportunity to bring young talented
asian footballers into football
to monetize of course the other side of
it for the eyes on the screen around the
world
it hasn't happened and the
representation is there why these
these people are not interested in why
they're interested in pointing their
finger at it and blaming somebody for it
rather than actually providing a
solution
and nobody wants a solution based upon
someone being positively discriminated
do they
i don't there's lots of people who do
but but it's funny
nor do we and it's funny you you talking
about many other things that we've
explored on the show these uncle toms
that you referred to we've had plenty of
them on the show yeah
we've had jordan peterson on the show um
but
it's interesting to me that you're
coming out so to just go back to
france's question
you've never had a conversation with an
owner of another football club who said
oh this guy applied but i don't like
them never anything nothing like that
and and i vehemently believe knowing
these guys because
we're you know us football club owners
are a certain mindset
and as i said lava flippantly you know
that they would have employed our summer
bernardin
if if we were alive and could have won
games for them that tells you that it's
not about color or creed it's not
people that seek to try to justify the
why there isn't representation or
advanced causes
you know uh may well advance that but i
genuinely believe that there are not
enough black coaches coming through
that are getting their badges i believe
that the
actual landscape when we talk about 30
because the
figure is advanced 30 of players in the
premier league are
from the black or minority ethnic
communities predominantly black
right and i know we've got to separate
the word bain now um because there's an
objection to that
that mnemonic i don't know what came
from the first place i never wanted to
use it i want to call black people black
but you know
we move and we adjust other times don't
we but when you actually distill that
down
and say well actually only 64 of those
players are indigenous to this country
it might give you an explanation because
a lot of people live in a country have a
contract play for a football team go
back to their own countries so they
don't form part of the statistic that we
should be really looking at
the representation isn't right but i'm
still not
understanding why that is the case and
taking of the knee
is a societal uh stand against
anti-discrimination but i don't believe
the national sport
is wrecked with discrimination so i
believe it's a flawed concept if you're
trying to get rid of racism in football
you you know the zero tolerance policy
that clubs have towards fans
is one thing but to suggest the sport
somehow as a discrimination problem i
i'm i'm troubled with not because i want
to be troubled by it because i have no
dog in the fight anymore
i don't own a football club anymore and
i'm only interested in authentic
uh observations that can affect change
not just being able to be utilized for
someone else's agenda that wants to
shout the loudest
and you we get that a lot i mean look
the the american football brought in the
rooney rule do you think that could be a
good idea
um i'm not against it they brought it
into the english football league which
is obviously the tier below the premier
league but they didn't do it properly
which is so often the case with football
that they brought it in without
reporting mechanisms they brought it in
as a protocol
and a guideline but they didn't bring in
reporting to
really be able to get underneath the
fingernails of how recruitment was being
done
how people were being given an
opportunity from all communities
i worry that it falls into a quota era
area
but anything that's fair and
equitable that advances opportunity for
talent then i'm
i'm for you know i built a business
that i was involved in very very heavily
you don't build a business
with 15 grand and in five years sell it
for the best part of a hundred million
quid
never having borrowed a money never had
any investors and just be different but
without really being underneath the
fingernails of it and i spoke to every
single member of staff on every single
induction course
on every single trading regime
instilling them in the belief that i
couldn't care
what they looked like where they came
from what their color creed was what
their ethnicity was what their sex was
all i cared about was that they did a
good job
and i gave them an opportunity to have
the opportunity they wanted which was
life is about success irrespective of
the measure of success
because we go to work to have a better
life outside of it i'm going to give you
the opportunity
to be successful i'm going to demand
from you your very best
if you work for me for six days six
weeks six months or six years i want
your best
six days six weeks six months or six
years and expect the same for me
and irrespective of what you look like
where you come from i will afford you
all those opportunities
and you will take them yourself and make
them yourself and i believe in that
emphatically so that then translates
into my outlook in life so i believe
religiously and emphatically in the fact
that talent is the definer talent is
defined and i
rail against the fact that people will
agenda rise
uh certain uh challenges that they may
have
and put it down to the fact that people
are suppressing them because of their
ethnicity i accept
i accept the argument in this country
that we have racism in this country and
exists on both sides of all communities
and i don't accept that the same issues
that happen in america which has a 40
racial mix towards latinos and the black
community
and the caucasian community whereas in
this country it's very different
dynamics
and i don't accept the societal issues
in america
exist here and i'm very challenged by
the
argument that's advanced and and the
regimes that are being deployed
to suggest this country is
institutionally racist i i don't accept
it
not because i don't want to because i
live in this country and i have open
eyes
and whilst i'm not black you know i've
been brought up with most of my friends
and i know that's a token argument that
people are advanced but my friend's a
black person
i have a black nephew who i watch the
world through his eyes as well
and i see the opportunities that he does
or doesn't have based upon his own
way of approaching life but i do accept
fundamentally accept that there is
endemic racism in this country in this
society
what does that mean well systemic means
that the whole country
every single institution is rife with it
endemic means it's localized
and it's not specific to you know it's
not an overall character there are
racist people in the country
of course well no one would deny that
you'd be insane to do so
but you know but the argument the
argument's not being advanced as a
choice is it it's being advanced that
this is country systemically racist it's
institutionally racist and i struggle
with that
i struggle with critical race theory
because it's about this
construct of the law designed to
suppress
one race in the advancement of another
and whilst i accept that it was
redlining in america and that people
were struggling to break out of economic
depravity specifically the black
community through the 30s 40s 50s 60s
and 70s and the italians and the jews
after the first and second world war
were allowed to break out of those and i
accept it and i understand
it and i think it's deplorable i do not
believe it exists in this country and
it's not because i don't want to
i want to see it i want to see terrible
things where they are and then i want to
make people accountable for them
when they really are accountable for
them
do you want to promote your business to
an intelligent audience who don't need
to know your pronouns to buy your
product
here at trigonometry we have over 250
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and we frequently get
over 3 million views a month that's a
lot of new customers
for your business we speak with some of
the biggest guests from the worlds of
politics
economics journalism arts and
entertainment
all of them have spent at least one
month in the gulag
so you don't have to and we'll match
your product to the perfect guest for
you
american sponsors will be matched with
american guests and so on
that way you know your advert has the
best possible chance
of getting to the right people or as we
call them the wrong people
advertise with us and we'll get your
business cancelled or your money back
contact us by email at marketing
trigger pod dot co dot uk and we'll make
your nightmares come true
you're a business owner yeah i mean this
has been not unlike
anything that any of us have seen yep i
mean
what are the challenges that you face
and do you think the government has
actually provided enough support
for people like you who are running
businesses to keep them afloat and what
well i think you know when we're in an
uncharted world i hate to use the
terminology unprecedented because it's
been flogged to death by everybody that
can't find an alternative
word but i think the government has
stepped up and done
far better than it's been given credit
for i think we're in a world where it's
very easy to sit on the other side of
the fence and point your finger at
what's not being done
rather than looking at the reality of
what has been done i'm not interested in
debt
costs and how much debt we've raised
because i think britain has the ability
to power out of this because there's not
anything fundamentally wrong with the
economics of this country we're actually
in ascendancy what's actually this is
not 2008 2009
where you've got a problem with the
constructs of the way that the banks
operated they were under capitalized
bazel
iii wasn't a part of possible the bank's
thinking they had fundamental problems
with the mayor in which they were
lending
wall street was driving the economics of
certain things
so you look at that and say when we shut
down in 2008 2009 and the world went to
hell in the hang cart economically
the situation was broken we're not
broken
we've just committed an enormous act of
self-harm
which is shutting the world down on the
basis
of i don't deny i'm not covert denier
i'm not a vaccine i'm not an anti-vaxxer
i am very troubled
by the manner in which the media has
created an
absolute fear culture around the disease
that doesn't seem to be fundamentally
different from the hong kong flu of 1968
when more than you know a million people
died around the world but nobody shut
the world down and i know rocco faulty
wrote an article about that saying does
anybody remember the hong kong flu
because i was around at that time no
nobody does because it wasn't leveraged
the way
it has been leveraged by the media i
have a great trouble with the media
because i think one of the worst
and that's ironic given the fact i
operate in it i understand that it's not
about being in the media it's about how
you are
operating within the confines of the
media one of the worst things
that's happened is 24-hour rolling news
cycles because you need to keep creating
content
that means you get 25 epidemiologists to
be able to contradict one another to be
able to keep the news cycle running
one of the most disgraceful things i've
seen recently was sky news
when we had the foresight in this
country to have the
medical the mhra were able to license
the vaccines
quickly before anybody else and they
flew over anthony falchi from new york
to give an opinion
on our vaccine saying that the standards
in america would be higher
for the regulatory granting of of the
licensing of vaccines
and then sky had the audacity after
creating
vaccine doubt had to the audacity in the
next cycle
to rail against the fact that anyone
should be doubting vaccine well we
weren't doubting vaccines until you came
along
and brought somebody over who had to
apologize a week later
and then the particular vaccine that he
was criticizing was then licensed by the
americans
so you know i have views about
the the the way in which the media
operate which concerns me it sounds as
if i've got an agenda with the media i
just want people to be given the right
information
and people to understand um that the
dynamics of the world we live in going
to the question
of how difficult it is i just scaled you
know i just scaled and moved into
capital opportunities
i've got of investments in startup
businesses that will obviously have been
very difficult during this period of
time
focused in retail retail was always
bleeding a lot of my friends were in
retail theo
fetus obviously with hundreds and
hundreds of stores they were already
getting their backsides kicked by the
online guys in terms of the fact that if
you've got retail footprints you're in a
difficult position because you're paying
rates
and you've got a cost of sale which is
dwarfed
by the cost of sale that the online guys
the amazons of the world have
so the challenges were there um as far
as
supporting the economics of businesses
yeah you can run an argument that people
weren't supported you can run an
argument that
there were certain smaller businesses
where directors weren't able
who paid themselves through dividends
weren't able to be able to claim the
same money that other people could claim
as a result of the furlough schemes well
i'm sorry with respect to you guys the
reasons why you pay yourself through
dividends
is because you get a tax break for doing
it and you declare less of an income
so you can draw less when a crisis like
this comes along you can't have it both
ways
i don't know what you're talking about
simon but the hypocrisy of certain
arguments i think the government
has had whoever was in situ
would have had a buggers muddle because
we talk about ppe
and the shortage of ppe i thought ppu
was perishable it is perishable
so how are you ever going to have stocks
of ppe because it's perishable
so the idea that we should be fully
loaded and
fully invested with a whole raft of ppe
available to everybody
was unfair i'm not suggesting we
couldn't have done better i'm not
suggesting the daily mail didn't prove
it by flying a plane out to such and
such a place and loading it up with ppe
i was also of the impression that the
the
the care service on the whole was
privately run
for people like my friend duncan
vanitine that make lots of money
from you know this sort of environment
so quite why it was responsibility of
government to be
procuring and securing their ppe at the
height of this particular challenge that
we had at the beginning of it
you know troubles me but the economic
landscape
yeah of course it's brutal and i think
there's been so much indecision and so
much
um we're being led by scientists we're
being led by
clinicians and the problem with that for
me and i'm not going to like what i'm
about to say
is these well these people live in a
world of research and development
they live with the with the desire to
allow you to live with things rather
than cure with
cure things they also never seem to have
any accountability you have back surgery
am i going to come out of this 100 okay
well there's no guarantee well okay but
you're the doctor
so can i have a guarantee a cast iron no
medicine doesn't work that way
when you put when you deploy a country
into the hands of people like this
then you're never going to get an
outcome that's never going to be
anything other than
never ever or yes it could be this yes
it could be that we could go on forever
so i have great trouble with
what's going on over the last 12 months
as we all do not just because it's
been debilitating for mental people's
mental well-being not because it's been
destructive because the media
have have run it like a rolling a
countdown of how many people are dying
running around like morbid but you know
sort of
digital birken hairs running around the
world chasing coffins
as if it's something we all want to see
but i'm not sure what else the
government
could have done besides do the economics
that it's done
and now i don't worry about the national
debt because i think
cost of borrowing is cheap we never
could have borrowed more money cheaper
and i think the
economy has the ability to power out of
it
myself and john caldwell don't agree on
many things having been old sparring
partners but i've seen john
with his narcissistically
uh titled call bull plan um about the
way to power out of this and
britain is a business model
in terms of its economic landscape to be
able to power out
of the challenges we've got the stock
market's been on a real opportunity
um that i've availed myself off and
taken you know invested in a lot of
covert stock companies invested in a lot
of the ftse
100 companies that have dropped off the
radar with the fundamentals being
okay but the sentiment driving the the
the lse
and various other markets so i
as a capitalist and a realist think in
every crisis there's opportunity
um we're seeing a changing landscape
we're seeing a change of the way people
were going to work
i'm interested to see how that lands
because whether people like it or not
people are more effective when they're
in environments where
people can see how they're working and
can manage their output
and i know people are not going to like
that but when we start to see the
development of
the live and work environments and the
way that residential commercial is going
to
going to morph into into one environment
and out of everything comes opportunity
but i think it's been brutal how can it
not be well
simon you made a couple of interesting
points there first of all the one about
the scientists i completely agree with
by the way
which is the whole thing about following
the science is an absurd way of for
politicians to protect themselves
abdicate responsibility
that's all it is right because there's
no such thing as following the science
uh politicians are supposed to take
their that information and put it
together with information about
mental health policing absolutely the
economy
all that together
but the real point i wanted to pick up
out of what you said was the media
because i'm someone who rails against
the media as much as anybody else
but do you think there's actually the
public
me you francis everybody watching we
have to take some responsibility i'll
tell you why
because they did a poll recently which
showed that
if you are if you poll people in this
country about how many people have died
what percentage of the public have died
a lot of
the most common answer is ten percent so
people think that six million people
have died right
they're out by a a magnitude of two
right it's actually 0.1 percent
so we've bought into this fear
right but my point is we've bought into
that fear
we the public you and i may have not but
but the people
have bought into yes the media of course
they keep telling us
it's all evil blah blah blah but we are
the ones that got scared
the public are the ones who watched all
that nonsense and actually decided we
must be scared
do you not think that while we try and
blame the media and say they're only
giving us what we want
um create the demand and then supply the
demand
right right so which is worse there is
an element of
people you know this may sound
condescending but it's not meant to
there are very few leaders in the world
most people are lemmings
they follow they they look to give their
get their opinions from other people
they
follow people's example whether it be
fashion or whether it's people's
opinions
if you've got broadcasters that are
constantly pumping information into you
there is an element of people a
proportion of society
that will suggest that because it's
being put forward by broadcaster because
it's being advanced by a politician that
has to have credibility
has to have substance and so
subsequently has to be believed now
other people
that are more prepared to kick the can
and to
interrogate it and to look behind it and
to evaluate it
without a gender because people that
evaluate things that don't always not
have an agenda they have their own
motivation to be able to
change it around to advance the argument
they want to at the time of course
there's an argument that you're
supplying people what they want
the sun being a newspaper that people
have vilified over the years yet still
probably the biggest selling newspaper
for a variety of reasons
you know i know people won't buy that
newspaper in liverpool because of what's
happened in the past there
but it still remains to be one of the
biggest red newspapers
irrespective of some of the
irresponsible piers morgan and some of
the things that he has said
i happen to agree with some of the
things he said about meghan markle and i
happen to agree to some of the things he
said um
about a lot of things but i don't happen
to agree that he's a shining light
of of of merit um especially on carving
uh on a variety of things he's a
hypocrites and we had him on our show
once and i drove a bus for his hypocrisy
and i don't know how he's got the
audacity to write a book about the
council culture when he's a living
embodiment of it
um and spends more of his time scoring
points
than actually dealing with something
more substantial when you get when you
get the health minister
on that ghastly show gmb and you haven't
had him for six months and rather than
talk about the progress of vaccines you
want to spend
a 15-minute interview suggesting dm we
should apologize for something that
dominic cummings did
then you're in a click-bait world of
news cycles rather than a real
broadcasting world that the public are
entitled to see
i accept that there has to be an element
of showbiz or razzmatazz or
feel about it that gives people what
they want to see at times
and of course there is always the
argument that you get where's the
we're only giving people what they want
but you know
you create that demand in them and then
you feed that demand and of course
there's a proletarian mentality people
can be proles
they can sit there and go more more i
want more of that because i like what
i've been given
and there is an element that people
should find out for themselves
i try to find out for myself i try to
look at the statistics
i try to understand 38 000 people in
hospital
and the hospitals are going to burst and
we've got the nightingale's been built
over there and why haven't we got this
and
what 128 000 people have died of this
dreadful disease but how many people
have
died with it and i'm hearing statistics
being reported that actually
the government have a motivation for
people and we hear all of these things
but i try to put it through a critical
lens
and understand it and i have very grave
concerns about the manner in which the
world is operating and the way that
we're being led to believe certain
things
um and but we almost take responsibility
for our own thoughts
that's what i'm saying you know and and
if we're all going to be terrible i mean
i'm personally not terrified i've
had covert 19. very unwell with it um
and i've had members of my family that
have had it and i don't want a society
where we're walking around in mosques i
don't want social distancing
i don't want to live in fear and covet i
want to learn to live with it
i want the actual facts to come through
about what's really happening with this
situation rather than
some of what seems to be happening and i
do agree emphatically with you
that there is an element of if you allow
scientists to to be
the leading force behind what you're
making your decisions upon then you are
abdicating responsibilities and i think
boris johnson
and his cabinet are very very much
guilty of that but when you've got
low-grade politicians that we have in
this country in this day and age
some of it could be because of the
nature of abuse that you get by being a
politician some of it could be
that you don't pay these people best in
class irrespective of the ridiculous
expenses
but you know we pay our politicians
boyce johnson's the ceo of this country
he's not paid like the ceo and it
shouldn't be about money
and we know that further down the line
he'll monetize it
by being able to sell his memoirs and do
whatever you know after the speeches
that he and tony blair
can do until the cows come home but it
still doesn't alter the fact that we
don't have the best in class whether you
like these people from the past or not
whether you like michael hesseltine and
think he was to be revered
my god these were politicians of stature
these were men of stature you may not
like their politics but you knew where
you stood with them
and we don't have this now we have
lightweight politicians that are
half-baked that are too busy virtually
signaling and actually doing what they
should be doing which is running this
country
and running it properly and having the
coverage of their convictions and i know
that sounds easy to stand today from the
outside but that's what leaders should
do
that's what leaders should be made of it
shouldn't be something we say oh wow
that's special
that's what our politicians should
embody
i mean it's very true all the points we
talked about
on the show all the time yeah we had
peter hitch and saying the exact same
thing i like peter yeah i like people
don't always agree with his articles but
i think he's got something to say and he
says it
if you're going to say something go
ahead go strong or go home exactly
and on that note we could have talked
for another hour assignment it's been
absolutely brilliant it's the end my
pleasure thank you for having me we're
going to do a couple questions for
locals but for the purposes of now we'll
wrap this up
yeah thanks very much for coming on
simon if people want to check out
where you are your controversial
opinions where do they go for that
online well if they like sports they can
listen to what i consider to be the best
broadcaster in the country which is
trigonometry
trigonometry besides trigonometry in the
digital world but um from
a sports point of view listen to talk
sport it's a great station
great stuff and the last question we
always ask is what's the one thing we're
not talking about but we really should
be
um you posed that to me earlier on and i
was trying to think if there is such a
thing as we're talking about i think
i think there is i think there are very
few things off the table right now
everything is being over analyzed from
how much a
prime minister spends on his car and his
on his wallpaper
through to the state of the nation so
i'm not i don't really look at anything
out there and say
we're missing a trick here i'm sure i
could have perhaps
delved deeper into my psyche and thought
of an answer i don't have one on the top
of my head thinking i've got a burning
question my boning question is
do we ask the right questions do enough
people that have enough intelligence and
and have the courage of their
convictions to advance arguments
get the opportunity to do so and are we
scrutinizing things
are we allowing things to go on this
country and not having because we're
living in this ridiculous woke mentality
where you dare say something that people
don't like
then automatically you're cancelled i
think we're going to see
and we should be loading and applauding
and an appreciation of people having
different views and learning to disagree
without the necessity to be able to
destroy one another
good point yeah uh thank you for coming
on the show simon and thank you for
watching and listening we will see you
very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one
or a raw show they all go out at 7pm uk
time take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below